let's do it from
my I just want to work on
the this part
here don't really care how you get
all right we have to empoy the same
thing we always
do we're not going to come up with a
different way
of generating a falling geometry okay
this is's a couple things different in
this one however from the when I
introduced the concepts to you they were
in
Naga okay we're we're now in pinning
technique so there's a there's one
subtle difference and that is that in
Naga I don't want the person near me I
want them to fall away from me but in
pinning techniques I want them under me
okay and the only thing that changes
there there in is how much I
displace their
Center uh outside of the Spiral okay so
we know we know
that um I'm in my x pattern right so
let's just
two-dimensionally you're you're going to
establish a
spiral with uh
UK UK center of gravity okay uh it's
going to go in the vertical in the
vertical plane uh in a circular fashion
and so now it's in the horizontal plane
so I'm either going to bring it up or
down at some point
probably both I'm going to bring it left
or right at some point and I'm also
traversing the mat so it's also moving
through the sagittal plane and once I
establish that Center that spiral I will
acknowledge where well where is the axis
of this
rotation uh once the spiral is
established and once I have that spiral
once I have this axis of
rotation at the time that I want them to
fall I am going to let's say this is
where their center of gravity is at this
point okay it's coming
around at when I want them to fall I am
going to push this center of gravity
outside of this spiral 90° to that axis
of rotation that's your CQ projection of
the x pattern that's what I call the x
pattern Okay so they're going that way
and here's your little X that's
happening okay because it's always on
some sort of
spiral uh I don't like the plus sign I
just like the feeling of the X okay I'm
never really making a plus sign there
okay all right so I have to do that in
eel the difference from this and cyho
when I introduced this geometry to you
is I don't I want them to fall
underneath me and not away from me so
all that Ma all that changes is how far
from that axis of rotation through the
spiral do I uh displace the center of
gravity that's the
okay uh no further than I can keep them
under me that's that's the rule
okay all right
so at a certain
point for the EDI in EO whether it
doesn't matter what the Vari ation is so
here we're
doing it doesn't matter if
it's it doesn't matter this is this is
how you always enter on aot okay at some
certain point you brought them into the
front
inward kazushi so you're going to get
some angle of their body we're going to
go here okay
they're going to be on one leg and then
the other leg is up in the air as you
started to tilt
them okay and I now have an
object very much like the Bulan I was
using in koky hole where the spine was
straight up and
down okay the first thing I do is I
tilted that spine this is just a review
of that video then I'm going to let the
feet keep
going then I'm going to bring the head
around and let it go back
around and then the body falls very
similarly only as to the front inward
which means I'm going to bring the head
around I'm going to let the foot go
around this way and then at some point I
know the center's a little off I'm going
to take the center and make it go the
other way way okay that's what I'm going
to do every single time I am not going
to take the body and just move it this
is very common so the spine would be
like this I'll show you again this is
very
common you get something like
this okay and then all they do this is
the spine is they just move it
over off of this Bas of support and then
then the person falls down okay I say
they don't all you have to do
is try it on someone who doesn't know
your choreography they don't fall down
they just keep stepping to reput their
base of support underneath the line of
gravity that's all that happens and then
the skilled fighter will use that one
time and then adjust to take your
leverage away from the arm and you're
not arresting anyone then that's what's
going to happen Okay but with this
component here the entire uh elements
that construct the basis support they
get sent off in three different
directions the dude's going to fall okay
and that's what we're doing so I'll show
you this variant here and then we'll
review again this variant which I was
demonstrating in the first clip again
we're working from
clot okay and so here the guy
is down and he's in that L shape this is
the incorrect way and then the I just
let me do it this time the idea is that
I'm going to shove him and then he'll
fall
okay here and I shove him and he falls
okay one and again
let's just do a couple of ways that he
can get a Bas of support back underneath
the line of gravity so this works if his
feet stays still if that foot stays
still then I can push the line of
gravity outside the Bas cor and he will
fall
okay if he puts his hand down he's going
to get his Bas of support and I didn't
get the thing I wanted okay
even if he doesn't move his foot and he
just puts his hand down when I
go I you're not going he's not going to
fall
okay but as you saw what he would do is
he moves in stages boom boom and he's
out he's out of the technique and the
pin is now not under me and he can use
his leg strength and just stand back up
and I can't get
there's also the assumption that I can
actually even push the line of gravity
out such that he would have to adapt you
see I don't know if I could do it on him
okay especially if he gets the other
foot
down then I can't do this thing okay I
can't do
it it's not going to happen let's see if
he has his foot up which makes no sense
in usually how you get here but I don't
think I could do it even th well barely
I can do it
okay what are we doing
instead well once we get him
tilt we bring his head around round my
kosy centrifugal energy takes care of
his feet
so we get him tilted I bring him around
here get the Tilt bring him body put the
body around that
way if we look at the other one even if
I was
successful he's not following the rule
of the pin being under me I have to now
catch back up to it but at this moment
it's not under me
the pin is under me so you have a brake
here which shows that you have a
pin okay
so the biggest mistake is where does the
x pattern go on his
body that's the biggest mistake
everyone wants to go like EO
Ura but it's not e
Ura
my hip goes in
here where I'm going to finally displac
it my hip goes in
here but I bring his head around with
his arm
so if you watch the other way watch his
hips watch his
hip so now let's pay
attention this can't go in his
armpit because it's his Center that I'm
just
placing he goes somewhere around the
hips around the pushies
let's get the the entry angle so round
the cushy then we'll work with how do
you actually enter and then we'll work
with what do you do with the
arm but it's important to note that in
the version that we do we always get his
inertia that's going forward we let it
go forward when we attack his body so
that his leg keeps going forward just
like just like
kof his body's going forward I want the
leg to go forward it doesn't matter if
it is katate same thing there's that leg
go okay
all right let's get to
our
[Music]
angle okay so he's up here come this way
CU we don't fil the
back and I'm going to move in
here so he would be on that
tilt we're just going to take his arm
out of the
technique I go right in front of him
arm out of the way I don't go over here
see this
space no no space see they go right in
front right
here so watch how I'm doing that right
in front of
him no space
he goes right on my
cushy no space no space here it's
wrong get rid of that space okay try it
okay so like most of the
Naga we don't do anything with the
feet on the on the falling
geometry once we establish the
rotation then the centrifugal energy
does what it does with the foot okay so
we don't I'm going to take that part off
because we don't need it I don't you
don't have to worry about it
here's really what we're dealing
with I am going to
cut that's my cou Vector which is
happening with my
Koshi on their
Koshi and then here here is
the distal end of the head side of the
lever of the spine it's these two forces
okay and what I'm doing
here is every time I have an
arc and that's what we're going to look
at
now I need to be in the middle of the
Ark
okay always in the middle of the
Ark and so this arm has to move around
moving their head around at the moment
that my
coosi is touching their
Koshi at the moment the space
time that this arm is moving around okay
and I'll show you what I
mean so if I don't move I know that his
arm does
that his arms going to go this
way his arms going to go this way
because it has to go around
me and so I know I need to be in the
middle of that motion as it goes around
me
and I know that I have to be touching
his
hip okay and I have to line these things
up and that's what I'm doing
here this
hand is on
the young
line
with the
qua and they move together so as I come
in
it goes around me what would be
incorrect
closed now I can't get in
there different you're closing it
or I enter on a straight line I'm
close but I'm entering on a straight
line now I can't get
there so when I
enter yes I am good going to start
straight but as I get in
there it's going to
turn
so yes it's starting straight but it
starts to
turn so I end up
here you
see not here
[Music]
different goes around me
and when it goes around
me it's under me I can crack the hell
out of that
thing
okaying
in
um I know in modern iido they talk
constantly like there's a counter to
every counter and I don't
agree uh what I would say is you're
going to have to free your
Center then there's a counter okay so it
can't just be a matter of you extending
the circle and that's just not right
that's so because the x pattern is there
uh it's not going to work okay when you
don't have the x pattern you just have a
some kind of weird two-dimensional
Circle or a line you kind extend the
line and then what was Nag's energy
becomes UK's energy okay so for example
if I'm doing that other version and I
shove him
out he can use that energy to keep
pulling me over him
okay we don't want it that's not right
okay so in this version the whole
goal is to not have that this shoulder
the one I'm trying to control go up it's
going to go down
down there's a lot of pressure
there I don't want the other shoulder to
go down and that shoulder to go up until
I get it down no that's
crazy
boom pressure into the
shoulder
boom Okay so this is another benefit
because I'm trying to pin him what am I
trying to pin the inside shoulder so the
inside shoulder has to go down not up
okay so let's try and make that point go
okay now if you if you have all those
concerns the the left hand moves with
the left quaw
okay uh I'm entering on a circle and my
goal is to get this shoulder down you
don't want to ever push this elbow in
that direction this elbow never goes
that way and then comes back to me now
that's not going to
work the elbow is going around me
because I'm the middle of the
circle not going this way you see and
then that way no no
no the elbows going around me this way
this
way then notice my arms going this way
with my
hips this
way never push then try to come up
no around
okay try that okay after a certain level
of uh you don't have the internal skills
you can't really do my variation okay uh
the hard part here on this one is uh
when when I'm about to move there's a
lot of inertia here cuz I took him that
way okay and there's going to be a point
where I'm on one leg so he's trying he
let's just he'll do a force Vector that
way go ahead and push you see I can't do
that I have to be able he's he's pushing
and I'm just here he can't can't push me
he's not going to push me over than and
so that's what allows me to bring it
around me as I'm entering
when you don't have that you're going to
push it off of your foot you see you're
trying to push it ahead of you and then
you're going to try to bring it around
that's not the thing okay well on on on
one foot it's already going around
[Music]
me you do energy going back that way
he's pushing this way okay oh uh on on
one foot it's already going around you
see so that was
my my Center Line my yang line so my
Jang Jing line my yang line and my qua
they they all moving as one
unit they're not going to disconnect
[Music]
they all move one one
unit one
unit my
hands all different circles there okay
try harder okay let's look at the x
pattern part okay so the displacement of
his center of gravity within the sadal
plane so it's not that I'm here and it's
just traveling around
me the the rotation doesn't start until
I have actually displaced it that's
where the rotation
starts so we'll put his foot on this X
and you close up on the X there's a X on
his foot okay and as I move I will do
the rotation but it doesn't happen here
on the shoulder like a UD there's an OT
there's Ani to it okay so as as I'm
coming in you'll see that his foot gets
moved before I do the rotation one more
time you can come closer Margaret so you
can see what I'm doing okay I'm not
going to go here and he goes this way
I'm not doing
that you're G to take that foot off of
that
X then it goes around me so if you watch
his bottom foot it's constantly being
pushed
out but with the circle not pushing it
out with the
line and push it out with the circle
[Music]
okay try it again